hi there here i am day one of the 90 day
challenge i'm in korean you're out there
doing your own languages
uh i didn't get as much studying in
today as i wanted i'm going to show you
a bit of a
a few snippets of what uh my day looked
like
i had hockey this morning we lost
then i went to buy a car
i've traded in my seven-year-old saab
for a 2013 volvo
main reason is because it handles the
phone bluetooth mp3 player all of that
stuff better so that when i'm in my car
i can be listening to languages i can
take a phone call without
causing an accident
uh so between that and stopping by in
the office and so forth and i had to
watch the vancouver canucks get badly
beaten tonight so i didn't get in as
much language learning as i wanted i'm
targeting three hours a day that's a lot
but i think i can do it if i take
advantage of all the sort of dead time
during the day
i know from experience that if i get
enough exposure i'm going to improve
in terms of my knowledge of korean i
have a good sense of how the grammar
works in general terms i can't
necessarily use it but i understand
because six seven years ago i did a you
know six months of you know working at
korean
my biggest problem is that i don't
understand when people talk i don't
understand even easy content on link if
i read it i can understand when i go to
listen i don't understand my brain is
not yet used to it so i have to get that
comprehension going if i have the
comprehension going then i'm confident
based on my experience that i will be
able to speak better
so what do i have to do i have to find
and for the next few days or so i'm
focusing on a lot of content that i've
already studied at link so there are
fewer new links to create i'm trying to
re-familiarize myself with korean doing
some easy content some difficult content
but eventually i want to find some
compelling content that's very important
i've always found for the other
languages that if i could find
interesting content with a voice that i
liked that i could listen to it and and
stay with that and it would really uh
improve me
so i'm hoping to find that in korean i
haven't found it yet uh it could be some
kbs drama i have to find where are the
transcripts with audio where is this
material
i'm not going to look for it in the next
couple of days but
over the next week or so i want to see
if i can't get this compelling
content that's going to help me because
i know that if i can be emotionally
attached to what i'm listening to and if
i can expose myself to enough of it then
my brain will get used to the language
and so that's what i'm going to do
so enjoy
the little kaleidoscope of what my day
was like and i hope we're going to stay
the course for 90 days if we make that
commitment and give ourselves that
intensity of exposure we will improve
thanks for